no more room that's the message from New
York's mayor to migrants who've been
arriving by the busload many sent here
by Republican governors in States like
Texas Arizona and Florida more than 90
thousand have been absorbed in the city
since last spring many are fleeing
poverty and in some cases persecution
hoping to gain a better life in the
United States
we gave them a place to sleep we gave
them food we ensure that the children
were in our school system and
incorporated into our school system we
cannot continue to absorb tens of
thousands of newcomers on our own
without the help of the state and
federal government
100 million dollars in emergency funding
from the federal government and
volunteer organizations like team TLC
have been providing things like clothing
toys for kids and legal advice
but the city is projected to spend more
than 4 billion dollars to house and feed
Asylum Seekers throughout the next year
with homeless shelters at capacity the
mayor is saying he will now limit adult
Asylum Seekers to 60-day stays and the
city is also passing out flyers like
this at the U.S Southern border warning
migrants that New York is expensive and
asking them to consider going someplace
else
the flyer warns there's no guarantee of
shelter something advocates for the
migrants contest
as a so-called Sanctuary City that
promises shelter for those in need New
York has been housing 55 000 of them as
they begin the lengthy process of
applying for work papers when the city
starts closing its doors while at the
same time saying we're a welcoming City
and we love immigrants you know you
can't have it both ways if we're a
sanctuary City if we welcome immigrants
if immigrants are the backbone of this
city and indeed this country then we
have to find Creative Solutions not just
turning our backs on them the mayor's
move is unlikely to deter people like
Eugenio from Venezuela
it's great here thank God we're in a
place with a developed immigration
process we already have clothes and
shelter at the hotel where they feed us
but mayor Eric Adams says the city can
no longer cope it's compassion for
migrants may be unlimited but resources
are not Kristen salumi Al Jazeera New
York